oh my gosh
[Laughter]
oh my God oh my God
oh my God the Apple's at first I have
never done an interview like this before
Heidi how are you honey I'm amazing how
are you guys this is the person okay
I have not I mean the rain brought you
out tonight but did you and Tom go on a
recent fishing trip to come up with this
wild idea you know what they say the
early bird catches the worm my husband
you know I'm the worm you're the worm
we're going fishing how many months did
this take to get you in this oh my
you're even so sleepy well what was
amazing for me today didn't take me so
long but to make the costumes took a
very long time
them
um
a few months you know to build this I
had a few fittings
um
how do you think of a worm I don't know
I just thought of you know some random
things last year I wanted to be a tree
but then um he thought that was
difficult to do so I kind of started
thinking outside the box and then I
thought a rain worm would be cute that's
something that we all know I don't
really love the worm that I've ever seen
in fisherman Tom over here
Tom when you married Heidi did you think
that this would I mean you were marrying
into this a Halloween spectacle I I
always loved Halloween myself so yeah I
was ready for it you were okay and
tonight Lenny's Here For the First Time
celebrating so where's my daughter she's
a little cat
arrival where is she is she not here
somewhere she's inside I believe can you
give us another secret about your
costume you had to get a spray tan
although I'm not even sure why Heidi
well I wanted to make sure I look good
underneath you right
Tom because at some point just for me
exactly
like that how many people did it take to
get you ready today oh there were a lot
of people there A lot of people I mean
you know they had to build this piece
before I think that was the hardest
thing to do
um and then I guess to kind of match my
face in it I can't I feel very
claustrophobic how did you even get here
honey I don't know yeah you know that
you just hit it up like this weather
down the streets I got ready here at the
Moxie but um you know I can only walk
very very slowly well thank you for your
time tonight you always just knock
Halloween out of the park
oh my gosh
foreign